Film Courage: Jason, when you were starting
out in this business what attitudes did you
have that were wrong in terms of how the industry
worked or how to conduct yourself in a meeting?
Jason Satterlund, Filmmaker: There's a
saying that youth is wasted on the young?
I think what that saying means is that
we especially when we come out of film
school or school we just have this inflated
sense of who we are, of how brilliant we are.
That is the number one killer of careers
that I think that there is and just having
this overinflated sense of what you can do.
I definitely suffered from that because I
we all who do this dreamed the big dream we
all watched that movie there was probably a
movie that you saw when you were young and
you were like I can do that and we are and
it's probably true that's the thing and then
we just start to build this framework of who
we are as people and then you actually get
into the world and start to try to work and
nobody looks at you like that especially because
well what have you done you're just you're 20.
that really was was a blow having a more of an
ego than I deserved if that makes sense I think
I never and one of the things that
really tripped me up for years and
it still has ripple effects to this day is that
I didn't understand the importance of a mentor
how much time that would have saved me if I had
just found someone to tell me what to do because
I had no idea we're just stumbling around in the
dark like how do you get the first job on set who
no one told me how to do that so years had spent
trying to figure out even how to get an internship
like my God it's so hard so being humble enough
to just say please give me some advice because I'm
just want to learn that kind of thing so those are
both probably fall under the humility umbrella as
far as the things that I did wrong I also think
that there is a that's the best way to say this
putting too much importance on oh this I'm going
to direct this two minute short or whatever and
putting so much importance on it that you end
up it it ends up breaking under the pressure
like just getting so wound up and so full of
anxiety over this one little opportunity that
you have that you end up locking out all of the
creativity you become Vision locked into something
that isn't working that kind of thing can
really kill you yeah because you want it so bad
yes and you're so you because you want it
so bad and because you want to do it right
and boy I had to eat there is a real
pressure to the fear of making a mistake
and that is something I wish that I could have
understood a lot earlier is that it's is if I
wish someone would have come to me and said it's
all right to mess up sometimes if you look at some
of the greatest moments in cinematic history
they were generally mistakes or improv lines
from an actor or some sort of something didn't
go quite right and that's the thing that's on
the film because it just had this real magical
to it when you're putting so much pressure on
making it absolutely perfect like you and Afraid
of the mistake you just kill all your creativity
that's such a dangerous spot to be I wish
someone would have told me that and I think
one of the thing I've noticed from
filmmakers who are very successful
is they have this very simple work ethic
that no one taught me that I wish I had known
and that is like for example I know a
couple screenwriters and they're I they're
their work ethic is almost identical they
have a set time they get up every day
and they do their morning routine whatever it is
brush your teeth work out whatever turn off their
phones and for a couple of hours block they right
right and write and write and write and write up
to the end of that little block of time whatever
they said usually it's at least an hour or more
they take a break they take their lunch they turn
their phone back on they check their Facebook and
whatever and then they turn it off again and they
write and they write and they write and they write
and they write and then they cut it off and now
they're free to relax I don't think I've ever
even heard of that done in any kind of filmmaking
class no one ever said to me like you need to be
super disciplined and guarded with your time to
make sure that you are honing practicing working
on your craft for set hours every single day I
didn't do that man a long time long time years so
and those years they slip in they slip by
and suddenly it's a decade and you just
aren't getting better you're stagnating you're
circling things right so I wish someone would
have mentioned that early on because it
would have also really helped this is how
people when they break through at Young ages
it's because they've been more disciplined
about that kind of thing I'm convinced of that
where you see them come out of the gate it's
like dang how did this guy get so good at 25.
probably because they were more disciplined
that very focused on their craft that
means being all alone probably working
on a script studying reading without looking
at their phones and all of that kind of stuff
but when you're young and you're thinking about
dating or whatever it is the distractions of life
it's it really will get in the way of of your
progress it'll just make it take a lot longer
I knew someone who didn't have a cell phone
when they first came out because they had such
pressure on them to be accountable for certain
people that they wanted their time in the car
to be uninterrupted and everyone would go why
doesn't this person have a cell phone and the
person would say that's my time when I'm driving
this is before driving on with that this was this
is early on when before it was this taboo as it is
now in dangerous but they were just like no that's
my time and and that's what I'm thinking that's
where I'm doing things I need to do for for my
day and I don't want to be disturbed I think
that's super vital it's really interesting to
me because this is something that I've fought
for in a nice and simultaneously struggle with
is this idea of I'm going to take from 8 AM to
10 am and I'm going to work my craft oftentimes
for me that's writing something but the minute I
do that the minute I hit do not disturb my phone
and start hitting keys my eyes drift over to that
phone and I want to see if anyone's messaged me
it is unbelievable that's called resistance
and it is a sneaky little bastard like it
it's it's I don't know where I think it comes
from a lot of places for a lot of people like
fear of success whatever you want to call it but
it is sinister the self-discipline that it takes
to actually go no I'm going to take this phone
I'm gonna put it in the other room and I'm going
to focus I'm going to turn off my email turn off
the messages on my laptop turn off social media
and I'm going to focus on my craft for this
too straight over I actually got an hourglass
that has a one hour timer on it I just flip
it over and I'll watch the sand go through it
and force myself to do it but every day it's a
struggle every single day that resistance thing
wants to fight you but consistently the people
I know who have broken through did that and
they did that for years where and what's crazy
is going back to what I said at the beginning
they create an enormous volume of work because
they're so dedicated if you're finding yourself
where you're working all day long on whatever it
is that you're working on it's probably some sort
of day job that you don't love and then you sit
down to write a screenplay that night for like 30
minutes while you're checking Facebook you're
you're just gonna take you're just extending
it out you're just like you're gonna take 30
years to actually get a meeting at that rate
yeah so I think it's important to pay attention
to that resistance because it looks like different
things to different people Listen to Some People
for People Pleasers they have the people pleasing
disease and they want to be able to be there
for individuals they want to be present for
friends and family but there can be demands
so yeah yeah this business this business is
I found that there is this intense amount
of anxiety attached to this industry I think
there's a lot of that attached to life in general
this is not just me talking but if you look at
societies worldwide and the amount of people who
feel anxiety depression and those kinds of things
there is so many people taking antidepressants
so many people dealing with this that they find
traces of it in the drinking water and we've seen
that I mean it's very well known in La there's so
many people on Prozac or whatever that it's
secreted and it ends up that's why we have to
have filters on all our sinks because it's all
in there well what's going on why is there so
many people so anxious and so stressed out and so
depressed I think that that that's already there
and then it's exponentially harder in our
own industry and I think that that comes from
and I hate this part of our industry this
comes from this place where there's there's
definitely a looking down the nose at
certain kinds of projects so like if
you I'll give you a perfect example I was
years ago I was looking at joining the DGA
and my bread and butter oftentimes is
doing commercial corporate stuff and a
lot of that's non-union but that pays it keeps
the lights on keeps keeps me working and it's
it's actually great it can be really great
fun work and fulfilling work I asked them
so if I go Union can I still do non-union work and
they're like well it's probably not a good idea
I'm like man I don't know if it's a good idea for
me to join at this point because I can't just stop
working what am I gonna do go bag groceries
until I get a union job and they said to me
when you decide to take your career seriously
then you go ahead and come on and sign up with
us that right there is exactly what I'm talking
about it's this little bit of arrogance with these
projects over here are legit Marvel movie whatever
you high-end music video Marvel whatever you you
have these little category of movies movies
I've heard of or a TV show that I've heard of
these are the legit ones everything else
over here if you're making a wedding video
or a whatever like those aren't legit those aren't
considered and you're and when people ask you that
anxiety-induced question what are you working
on and the only thing you're working on is a
Colgate commercial it's this flood of anxiety that
comes up it's everyone I know struggles with it
they struggle with it especially when they're
not working when you haven't when you're going
to that event or even to a friend's house
because that the question is inevitably coming
what are you working on and if you haven't been
working what are you going to say like it is so
oh it just it just fuels us all and even people I
know who work a lot struggle with the same thing
and I've spent a lot of time trying to
figure out what that is and how to how
to work with it and I do think there are ways
to fight it I think the number one thing is
changing your relationship to anxiety
because when we experience it when it
crops up we see it as a negative
right it doesn't feel comfortable
there is a method in that I've heard that I
practiced through meditation called noting and
that means when you feel the negative feeling or
I shouldn't say negative the feeling of anxiety
comes up to take one second and step back from
it and go okay I'm experiencing anxiety is this
positive or negative anxiety positive because
there is positive anxiety positive anxiety would
be like I got this big pitch meeting tomorrow
at HBO or my film's in the contest I hope I win
that's positive that's cool like I'm about to
screen something oh my hope my friends like it
that's exciting right that's a good kind of
anxiety and when you're experiencing it and
you're taking a second to look at it and
go oh well of course I'm on edge because
my film's about to scream this is that's
a good that's okay and it's okay to feel
that there's also negative anxiety like
why Won't Anyone hire me things like that
now when you note these feelings it's I think
really vital to not judge it it you are not
trying to change it you are just recognizing it
I'm feeling anxious because rent is due and I
haven't been working okay well what that's a
rational fear that is of course who wouldn't
feel anxious there's something about just giving
yourself a little permission in some of those
cases to just be okay with it okay yeah this is
a real threat I need a place to live or whatever
because you don't want to get into the Trap of
being anxious because you're anxious because
that just does this right so noting like
just recognizing it and then changing your
relationship to what it is you can also take
a look at it and is this a thinking or feeling
kind of thinking would be rent is due this is
a fact it's due on the first and I don't have
it that's a fact feeling is man every time it
gets cloudy and rainy I just feel down like
that's a feeling so again you're not changing
it you're just changing your relationship to it
when it rears its ugly head and going oh it's a
it's a negative feeling and it's just a feeling
okay well what I like hot chocolate I'm gonna go
get one of those and just recognize it for what
it is I'm not going to try to change it I'm
just going to be okay with it I think that's
a that's a huge huge first step of dealing
with it the second thing I would say is that
you really need to pay attention to the
people that you hang around with because
they say misery loves company and what that
means is when you get into a whiny mood like
finding other people to whine with there's a lot
of power in that and it all it does is it it just
feeds on itself it becomes the sloop and you can
end up becoming more angry and more frustrated
I would say challenge yourself to to be around
people who are relentlessly optimistic or try to
change your group's mindset to hey I know we're
frustrated that we haven't been working but
what if we just made something ourselves in fuel
some hope into this group that you're in if you
can't change your group right or find a different
group I think that's super super important um
the third thing I would say that I think
this has been a big one for me is that
they say that the number one way to fight
feelings of anxiety is to find a community
anxiety loves it when you're alone depressed
people when people commit suicide they're
not in groups they're by themselves there's
reason for that one of the best ways is if
you're surrounded by people who especially in an
optimistic positive environment and I would say
that this group shouldn't be filmmakers somewhere
else now I think and it's even better if it's
active like something physical but it can be
kickball league or knitting or martial arts or
ballroom dance or horseback riding just some sort
of community regular community activity where you
are plugged into a bigger family of people that's
not filmmaking related is so incredibly powerful
I personally I found Jujutsu that was my
big it really helped me a lot and because
in Jujutsu I took it for self-defense they
say that judges is one of the best martial
arts for self-defense because in street
fights things generally go to the ground
and when you're on the ground how do you deal
with someone on top of you trying to choke you
so I started getting into that and the thing
that's here's what happens in my own Journey
I'll be anxious about something that anxiety rears
its head ah why didn't I get that job or whatever
I won't want to go it's one of my buddies
from class will go dude bro you coming
yeah I'll be there I go to class I'm feeling
I'm sitting in the car in the parking lot ah
I should go home and work on that script
or whatever no I'm the class is starting
in two minutes I'll go in I go in the
minute I hit the mat and so some kid
is on my back trying to actively choke me
guess what I'm not thinking about anymore
but never call me back I'm not thinking about the
thing that's due tomorrow I'm thinking about not
getting choked by this animal that's behind me
that is and when I'm done and it's a not only
is it an amazing physical sport like you are
exhausted by the end but it's a huge endorphin
dump you're just like foom and you're around
a whole community of people who are learning
a skill getting better focusing on something else
they're making their lives better these are people
they all have their own interesting and Rich lives
you are out of that artist Community for just a
second and you're just enjoying some great social
time in another group I come back from that and I
am super charged when it comes back oh oftentimes
I'm on my way home like I know what to say to that
guy to get him to call me back yes that's what
I'm gonna it's I'm usually on a huge Euphoria
high at the end of it community community is so
important like I would highly recommend and I
know that the first step to doing that it's
always hard like to they say in Jujutsu the
hardest belt to get is the white belt because
it's forcing yourself out of the house into
this straight group of strangers for the first
time but man please go out and get that done
and finally I would say when you if you
find yourself dealing with it there is
a lot of comfort in the fact that if you are to
to make sure that you are working on your craft
continuing to make progress every
day there is a lot of comfort when
you get to the end of a year and realize
you wrote three screenplays that year that's
that feels really good or you took a whole writing
class and graduated or whatever it is like that if
you are not continually like getting better
and practicing and feeling yourself improved
that feels really good that that can also
because you'll know at the end of the day
at five o'clock when you log off and you
decide to stop put writing aside for a minute
you can go play video games in peace because
you put in the work that feels nice you can
relax because you did your work for the
day that that's a really satisfying feeling
did you ever need to use any of the moves
in Jujutsu in real life in real life
let me think well interesting story so in my own
journey I had some very aggressive fathers so my
both were bullish both had a lot of street fights
so as a kid I grew up feeling utterly powerless
this really carried over in a career by the
way like as I would approach people that I
was intimidated by like that inner feeling of
powerlessness was really strong and so when
I went into Jujutsu I was absolutely terrified
like to I was essentially finding my own strength
I was taking class for about a year and a lot
of the at least the school that I attend is
all about self-defense it's just someone on the
street comes up to you and does this here's some
things you can do at least to keep yourself safe
anytime I'd ever been in an aggressive situation
it looked like something was about
standing in a bus stop in some aggressive
was going to come up to me I'm absolutely
terrified and and wish I could run away
right before the very first day of
shooting the abandoned my last feature
I hear a crash downstairs in the house that
we're staying in three o'clock in the morning
I get up out of bed I'm totally drowsy my
dog is freaking out I walk downstairs and
there's a guy standing in the kitchen now it
was the weirdest most surreal thing because
I was I was still just a very new practitioner
of Jujutsu I didn't I'm no I'm no badass
but it was the first time in my life where
I'm faced within a potential aggressive
person and I felt peace because the
way the guy the guy was standing in
the kitchen leaning on the counter kind of
hunched I thought he was going to rush me
but I pray in practice saying what happens
when someone rushes you in class for a year so
I just in that moment I just looked at him and
I thought okay well if he rushes me that's okay
I know how to deal with this I can at least
keep him from getting to anyone else in the
house while they call the police or whatever we
can get this handled so in the end it turns out
he was drunk and he found himself in the wrong
house now I didn't know this at the in that first
half a second when I saw him in the kitchen for a
couple of minutes there it was real Touch and Go
prior to that I probably would
have grabbed the knife or
freaked out or whatever but it really
did in a very positive way change
it was a great way to start shooting the movie
to just have that calmness in the face of that
kind of adversity was was really was really
great and it could be inspiration for your next
script I mean how bizarre is that that someone
accidentally goes into the wrong house but I guess
right we all look the same I don't know when
it comes to inspiration for that I mean I have
we'll say that when you learn some when you
get involved with some other sport or some
other skill you're increasing your skills in
some other way it really does fuel ideas like
if you're whatever horseback riding class you're
gonna be on that horseback riding you're going to
be riding that horse you're gonna be thinking
man wouldn't it be cool to write a story about
someone on a horse who's it's going to happen
it just will if you're an artist that's that's
one of the advantages to doing that but yeah
glad everything was okay yeah oh yeah yeah.